po sometimes gets a reputation for being
challenging and rightly so there's a lot
of work involved but it does have to be
said not every poy trick is hard there
are some of them that are remarkably
simple that's what we're going to look
at
[Music]
today Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm going to
break down five simple po moves that are
still favorites of mine that I use
almost every day but before we dive in I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark bunk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro teror light
toys spinballs and Ultra poy for helping
to make the videos on this channel
possible you can learn more about all
these awesome companies and the work
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission so clearly we've all
seen people online tearing it up with a
variety of different poy tricks whether
it be complex tosses contact poy or even
just Wild Tech from back in the day
there are so many examples of things
that just make our brains go ouch but it
doesn't have to be that way not every po
trick needs to have a three- syllable
name or would be something that requires
a 100 hours of practice in order to get
down so I wanted to share with you five
of my picks for simple po moves that I
think are still worthy of everyone's
attention and yes I know that the
definition of what is simple versus what
is complex or difficult is a highly
subjective one and sometimes people have
an intuitive grasp of something that
other people find really really
difficult and complicated but I truly
believe that these are five P tricks
that are simple overall and that are
simple for people to wrap their heads
around if you disagree with me you can
definitely let me know in the comments
so without further Ado let's dive
in trick number one Tic
Tacs so I think a lot of people would
consider these more an exercise than an
actual poy trick but I disagree I mean
sure these are super useful for getting
down basic information on how to bend
the plane of the POI back and forth this
is a basic building block for getting
down everything from two beat weaves to
later on getting down body tracers and
the like but doesn't have to be the
beginning or end of the story see I
believe that if you're creative enough
you can make any poy trick pop let me
show you we can use a simple Tic Tac for
getting back and forth across a
stage for pausing in a really dramatic
pose and for creating moments that are
sassy or silly depending upon which
flavor you prefer there are a lot of
options here and granted all those
examples are just with one po moving at
a time which I think there's still
nothing wrong wrong with that but if you
want to get two poy moving well that
takes us to the second trick on my
list trick number two
butterflies so I will confess that I
think I learned butterflies the hard way
and when I discovered that there was
another way to learn them I
retroactively looked back and felt
really really bad for my younger self
for having to go through that experience
I can't remember who it was that showed
me this technique but essentially you
can start by just creating big circles
with your arms that overlap with each
other and then using the pois extensions
of your arms from there you work your
way down to smaller and smaller circles
until you're just performing them from
your wrists goodness I wish in my first
year I had known to do this this way and
once again the lowly butterfly doesn't
have to be boring if we get creative
with it in particular I love changing
the volume of butterflies going from
performing little circles to performing
big circles I also love performing reels
with them turning with them as I walk
through a space there's a lot of
different options here now you'll note
both of the tricks that I have put out
there have been more about moving
through a space than they are
necessarily moving between petrix but
we're going to tackle that question with
our next trick here trick number three
pendulums so real talk I think that
pendulums are the unsung heroes of the
poy world no joke not only are pendulums
a great way to switch the direction of
the prop and therefore transition
between tricks but they're also a good
way to begin building a relationship
with the momentum of the prop being able
to perform pendulums allows you to add
and subtract energy to the POI as
they're spinning this becomes incredibly
important down the line for everything
from isolations to hybrids and it can
all start right here plus which they are
that odd poy trick to learn where the
likelihood of hitting yourself as the
POI goes over your hand does not exist
whatsoever so they're a loow impact way
to get into POI Transitions and what's
even better than that they work for any
form factor I don't think I realize the
full power of pendulums until I had a
student who was working almost
exclusively with programmable POI we
soon discovered that pendulums were the
ideal way to do transitions with them
because stalls just don't look very good
with that Long Rod form factor once that
got broken open I realized that they
were not just a powerful transition tool
for this form factor but also for
beginners in general and I've never
forgotten that lesson all right so thus
far we've played around with plane
bending we have broken down some
barriers with our butterflies and we've
even pushed the poy back and forth in
pendulums so what's left for us to do
well how about we explore some
space trick number four
reals so this was the very first poy
trick that I ever learned and it's
usually the first po trick that I teach
other people as well but I think it's
also one of the most powerful things
that any of us can learn as pois
Spinners and it has long-term
implications way down the road through
reals we learn the basics of plane
facing that is depending upon which side
of the POI plane you're on the PO might
appear to be spinning one of two
different directions this is really
helpful when it comes to Turning with
the POI and this Inn of itself is a
really powerful realization to have but
what that actually does for us is it
opens up freedom of movement in some
incredible ways we can actually take our
reels and break them down into different
planes stopping in wall plane in wheel
plane and everywhere in between
developing true freedom of movement with
the POI this is an essential aspect to
PO dance and something that you need to
know if you're going to explore this
space with any other poy tricks and I
don't think it's a coincidence that
there are so many po videos out there
where people just stop exploring the
space around them I think to a certain
extent we think of this as being a
beginner trick and we fall off the wagon
of using it to explore the space around
us and I think that that is a shame and
now before I share with you my final
pick for my five favorite simple poy
tricks I do have a favor to ask if
you've come this far in this video I'm
imagining it's because you have at least
a passing interest in po spinning and
maybe flow arts in general and the good
news is that I produce a lot of videos
on those topics so if you want to get
into the loop and know exactly when I
drop a new video please make sure to
subscribe to the channel it also helps
other people find my videos and it helps
my channel grow so please and thank you
and now for my final pick for my
favorite simple poy trick it
is anti- spin
flowers all right put away the
pitchforks and the Torches I swear to
God this is actually a simple poy trick
if it is simply taught the the right way
I had the most awful time learning
anti-spin flowers back in the day and
then magically alien John taught me a
new technique for teaching these flowers
and suddenly the clouds parted and the
angels sung and it became something that
was easy enough for me to teach people
who had just picked up their POI for the
first time the trick was learning to do
it through linear isolations and then
expanding out the hand path after all
the theory behind anti-spin flowers is
pretty easy to understand the hand goes
one way and the poy goes the other way
and it results in these long skinny
flower petals that point out away from
the center but getting from the theory
to the practice was always the Big
Challenge and I have to admit the funny
thing about teaching this trick this way
is if I don't approach it making the
student think that it's a difficult or
complex trick it tends to make it easier
for the student to put the pieces
together sometimes we subconsciously
send cues to people telling them things
that make their Learning Journey more
difficult and granted I'm really only
demonstrating it here with just one hand
but hey the first item on the list was
also demonstrated with just one hand so
I am comfortable including it here as my
favorite simple poy trick what did you
think of my list was there a simple poy
trick that I left out that is one of
your favorites please leave me a comment
and let me know what it
[Music]
was this video would not be possible
without my amazing patreon supporters in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission and if you out there watching
like the videos that I make and you want
to continue to see me make more of them
there's an easy way to make that happen
head on over to patreon at patreon.com
drexfactor pooy and sign up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out and
supporting me in my mission of bringing
po spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you and if you'd like to see
some of my favorite hard poy tricks I
will go ahead and include a link to that
video down in the description as well as
up here on screen thanks so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon take care now peace